president Trump and former Vice
President Joe Biden are trying to fire
up their bases in key Battleground
states with just 17 17 days now left in
the campaign Biden focused on healthc
care meeting with voters in Michigan and
Pennsylvania on Friday Mr Trump defended
his own struggle to contain the pandemic
during a series of rallies in Florida
and Georgia Nicole Killian is at the
White House with more on this Nicole
good morning hey good morning to you
Jeff and later today president Trump
will hold rallies in Michigan and
Wisconsin even even as Corona virus
cases hit record levels but the Trump
campaign says it is taking strong
precautions for its
events president Trump returned to the
White House after a rally double header
in Georgia we're winning in Florida
we're winning
here and Florida where he brought up Aid
hope Hicks who contracted the Corona
virus nearly two weeks ago right before
he did we can share a microphone now at
each stop the resident went after
Democratic rival Joe Biden making
dubious claims and egging on supporters
who put a new spin on an old chant that
Biden family is corrupt it's a corrupt
family I'll tell you something though I
just to lock them up you shouldn't lock
them
up lock up the bidens the president
resurrected a New York Post story that
stirred controversy this week the paper
published what it claimed were emails
allegedly taken from a laptop belonging
to Biden son Hunter CBS News has learned
the FBI is now looking into whether the
information found on the laptop may be
part of a Russian disinformation
campaign and unfortunately it sounds
like he left his laptop behind or they
have
thousands the former vice president
dismissed the reports when pressed by
CBS
News I know you'd ask it I have no
response it's another smear campaign
right up your alley they're the
questions you always ask it followed a
day of back-to-back events in Michigan
what the hell is the matter with this
guy from a Detroit Drive-In to a
socially distanced stump in Southfield
Biden slammed the president's pandemic
response and his mostly maskless Mass
rallies how many times Ontell he make
fun of Biden wearing a
mask because he
refuses to practice social distancing
puts his supporters in such Jeopardy the
Biden campaign also announced former
president Barack Obama will hit the
trail next week in Philadelphia he
readied his pitch at a senate fundraiser
Friday night people used to call me no
drama Obama well it's true I I tend to
be pretty steady you know I don't engage
in a lot of
hyperbole um but this
one uh really is the most important
election that I can think of
President Obama went on to say that he
believes president Trump is dividing the
country last night president Trump took
aim at his predecessor calling him an
ineffective campaigner Dana Nicole thank
you